one of the concerns that people have
in this modern world the digital data is
that of privacy and security
but privacy you know they're concerned
that when they share data
it's the same thing with you when we are
trust other human beings
uh in being fragile and revealing
something that we're vulnerable
vulnerable about there's a there's a
leap of faith there's a leap of trust
that that's going to be just between us
there's a privacy to it and then
the challenge is when you're in the
digital space then sharing your data
with companies that use that data for
advertisement all those kinds of things
there's a hesitancy to share that much
data to share
a lot of deep personal data and if you
look at brain data
that feels a whole lot like it's richly
deeply personal data so how do you think
about privacy
with this kind of ocean of data i think
we got off to
a wrong start with the internet where
the
basic rules of play for the
for the company that be was if you're a
company
you can go out and get as much
information on a person
as you can find without their approval
and you can also do things to induce
them
to give you as much information and you
don't need to tell them what you're
doing with it
you can do anything on the backside you
can make money on it but
the game is who can acquire the most
information and devise the most clever
schemes
to do it that was a bad starting place
and so we are in this period where we
need to wreck we need to correct for
that
and we need to say first of all the
individual
always has control over their data
it's not a free-for-all it's not like a
game of hungry hippo but
they can just go out and grab as much as
they want so for example when
your brain data was recorded today the
first thing we did in the kernel app was
you have control over your data and so
it's individual consent it's individual
control
and then you can build up on top of that
but it has to be based upon some clear
rules of play if
everyone knows what's being collected
they know what's being done with it
and the person has control over it so
transparency and control so
everybody knows what does control look
like me my ability to delete the data
if i want yeah delete it and to know who
is being shared with under what
you know what under what terms and
conditions we haven't reached that level
of sophistication with our products of
if if you say for example hey spotify
please give me a customized playlist
according to
my neurom you know you could say you can
have access to this vector space model
but only for this duration of time and
uh and then you've got to
delete it we haven't gotten there to
that level of visitation but
these are ideas we need to start talking
about of how do you how would you
actually structure permissions
yeah and i think it creates a much more
stable set
for society to build where we understand
the rules of play
and people aren't vulnerable to being
taken advantage
it's not fair for an individual
to be taken advantage of without their
awareness with some other practice that
some companies doing for their sole
benefit
and so hopefully we are going through a
process now where we're correcting for
these things
and that it can be
an economy wide shift that
because really these are
these are fundamentals we need to have
in place it's kind of fun to think about
like uh
in chrome when you install an extension
or like install an app
it's ask you like what permissions
you're willing to give and be cool if in
the future it says like
uh you can have access to my brain data
i mean and if it's it's not unimaginable
in the future
the the big technology companies have
built a business based upon acquiring
data about you that they can then create
you a model of you and sell that
predictability
and so it's not unimaginable that you
will create with like kernel device for
example
a more reliable predictor of you than
they could
and that they're asking you for
permission to complete their objectives
and you're the one that gets to
negotiate that with them
and say sure but it's not un
unimaginable that might
be the case
you